By the way, why don't you guys take the Academy Knights exam next week?
Brother, Rei probably
doesn't know about the Academy Knights, right? Oh yeah, and what about the
Academy Knights? There's the student troubles, the subjugation of
monsters on the premises, etc.  It's a
traditional organization that is in charge of things like that, like a self-governing organization within the academy, and only the elite who have passed the Monda experience are allowed in. It's
worth a try.
Academy Knights Well, they also appear in the game, so
of course you should know about them.  It's called the Teru Knights, but it's
basically a student council.If you join, you
can see special stills with the princes, but
in terms of the game, it doesn't matter whether you join or not.Why are you
not interested?  I thought I would participate, but now
I'm going to
say something like Knight-sama who protects Claire
Protect Claire-sama
[Music]
Someone helped the knight
[Music] Lady, I
'll accept my knight. What are you delusional about?  I don't even want to
know, but I'm
going to take the knighthood exam as well. It's a
shame that it seems like I've missed out. That
means, put it down. I can't stay protected forever.
I can fight,
too. It's weird.  do something wrong